the joggin experience one of my favorite
books ever about politics is fear and
loathing on the campaign yeah I wrote
the introduction to that did you had to
let the last the last edition of that
that raitis book yeah it's a fantastic
book and it's a great example of someone
who knew that they weren't a part of
that system so they could talk about it
as an outsider he knew he was only gonna
be covering it for a year you just went
in guns blazing and got everybody [ __ ]
up drinking on the bus making everybody
do all of them you know yeah and he says
that in the book he's like I was like
look this isn't my beat I don't have any
friends I have to keep you know yeah so
I'm gonna tell you everything that I see
yeah and [ __ ] it and and that's that's a
real problem in reporting when you when
you you're in a beat for too long you
end up have developing unhealthy
relationships with sources and you end
up in a position where you're not going
to burn the people who you're depending
on to get your information and when that
happens to reporters I think that's one
of the reasons is good to to kind of
cycle through different topics over the
course of your career if you get stuck
in the same same beat too long
eventually that you fall into that trap
the Thompson of course never did that
like you know every story that he
covered was he let it all hang out and
just said whatever the hell he thought
and you know he let the chips fall where
they may and that's kind of the way I
mean you can't do that all the time
probably but I think that's the thing
that was great it was amazing and
there's no other examples of it no no
I'm like that yeah yeah yeah I mean that
book was so great on so on so many
levels like he I always thought it was
being also kind of like a novel because
it's a it's this story about this person
who's like obsessed with finding meaning
and truth but he he could he goes to the
most fake place on earth which is the
campaign trail yeah to look for it and
so all these depictions of all these
terrible lying people they're just so
hilarious and and and so it's kind of
you know it's almost like a Franz Kafka
novel it's amazing and then it's great
journalism at the same time like he's
telling you how the system works and how
elections work and it's really valuable
for that so yeah that was brilliant he
also changed a lot I mean he actually
affected
tsch ins like the [ __ ] they did with ed
muskie were that was fantastic
when he was on the Dick Cavett show and
Dick Cavett asked him about it he goes
well there was a rumor that he was on
ibogaine and I started that rumor I mean
it's just he like literally that he got
in that guy's head oh yeah and the I
remember the he put that picture of
muskie and he just found a picture of
muskie and it's he's basically like that
yeah the caption is muskie in the throes
of a nibble gain frenzy right and you
couldn't get really get away with that
now like he just he just you know it's a
crazy drug to choose too because the
drug that gets you off addictions right
yeah exactly it's one of the more
hilarious aspects of his choice but it
sounded great yeah with the Brazilian
witch doc yeah yeah yeah it was
fantastic so good yeah but you know that
that kind of stuff probably wouldn't go
over all that well right now
yeah get sued yeah but the that also he
had this very very sort of a
aggressively characterizing way of
looking at politics and and politicians
and that that wouldn't go over that well
now either like people don't want you to
rip on the process as much as he did in
that book so it was great it was just a
fantastic book yeah I mean he had a
bunch of them that were great but that
one particularly it's you can sort of
redo it you could reread it every time
we get to an election cycle you can sort
of look goes oh you it lets you know
these are these are repeating cycles
this this is just like the same [ __ ]
that he was dealing with in you know
various different forms but you can see
it all today and it's funny
the reporters everybody's read that book
everybody who covers Kent in the
campaigns you know I'm on my fifth right
now for Rolling Stone like I had I have
his old job and everybody has read that
book and so they're they unconsciously
try to make the same characters in each
election cycle so there's always like a
christ-like mcgovern figure
there's there's a you know a turncoat
Quisling spineless musky figure there's
the end here's the the villain Nixon
trumpet Trump kind of fills that role
for a lot of reporters now and then
they'll a lot of them try to behave in
the same way that their characters
behaved in that book so you remember
Frank mankiewicz was was McGovern's sort
of handler and he was having beers with
with Thompson after the events and kind
of you know strategizing with him the
reporters try to do that they all try to
do that with the candidates and their
handlers now they try to develop those
same relationships it's just interesting
it's like they're really reliving the
book you know that's a problem with
someone that's really good you know they
take on so many imitators and there's so
many imitators take on their demeanor
and their thought process like and
Hunter was just such an iconic version
of a writer that it's it's so difficult
if you're a fan of his to not want to be
like that guy
oh totally I mean I you know I I know
that I know that you know especially
because I'm writing for the same
magazine and covering a lot of the same
topics you have to immediately realize
that you can't do what he did like he
Thompson's writing was incredibly
ambitious and and unique he he was using
a lot of the same teks
techniques that the great fiction
writers used like he was creating almost
like this four dimensional you know
story but at the same time it was also
journalism like you you can't really
most people couldn't get away with that
you have to be a great great writer I'm
not talking like over rare Mark Twain
level yeah talent that really did to do
what he did which is kind of mix the you
know the ambition of great fiction with
with journalism so if you try to do that
stuff it's gonna be terrible and I've
done I've certainly if you look go back
and look at my read and you'll find a
lot of like shitty Thompson imitations
and and so I learned to not do that
pretty early but ya know it's one of
those don't try this at home things for
young writers if you can if you can
avoid that for sure
[Applause]